how is it that so many intergalactic
species in movies and TV just happen to
speak perfect English the short answer
is that no one wants to watch a starship
crew spend years compiling an alien
dictionary but to keep things consistent
the creators of Star Trek and other
science-fiction worlds have introduced
the concept of a universal translator a
portable device that can instantly
translate between any languages so is a
universal translator possible in real
life we already have many programs that
claim to do just that
taking a word sentence or entire book in
one language and translating it into
almost any other whether it's modern
English or ancient Sanskrit and if
translation were just a matter of
looking up words in a dictionary these
programs would run circles around humans
the reality however is a bit more
complicated a rule-based translation
program uses a lexical database which
includes all the words you'd find in a
dictionary and all grammatical forms
they can take and set of rules to
recognize the basic linguistic elements
in the input language for a seemingly
simple sentence like the children eat
the muffins the program first parses its
syntax or grammatical structure by
identifying the children as the subject
and the rest of the sentence as the
predicate consisting of a verb eat and a
direct object the muffins it then needs
to recognize English morphology or how
the language can be broken down into its
smallest meaningful units such as the
word muffin and the suffix s used to
indicate plural finally it needs to
understand the semantics what the
different parts of the sentence actually
mean to translate the sentence properly
the program would refer to a different
set of vocabulary and rules for each
element of the target language but this
is where it gets tricky
the syntax of some languages allows
words to be arranged in any order while
in others doing so could make the muffin
eat the child
morphology can also pose a problem
Slovene distinguishes between two
children and three or more using a dual
suffix absent in many other languages
while Russians lack of definite articles
might leave you wondering whether the
children are eating some particular
muffins or just eat muffins in general
finally even when the semantics are
technically correct the program might
miss their finer points such as whether
the children manzano the muffins or de
Verano them another method is
statistical machine translation which
analyzes a database of books articles
and documents that have already been
translated by humans by finding matches
between source and translated texts that
are unlikely to occur by chance the
program can identify corresponding
phrases and patterns and use them for
future translations however the quality
of this type of translation depends on
the size of the initial database and the
availability of samples for certain
languages or styles of writing the
difficulty that computers have with the
exceptions irregularities and shades of
meaning that seemed to come
instinctively to humans has led some
researchers to believe that our
understanding of language is a unique
product of our biological brain
structure in fact one of the most famous
fictional Universal translators the
Babel Fish from The Hitchhiker's Guide
to the galaxy is not a machine at all
but a small creature that translates the
brainwaves and nerve signals of sentient
species
through a form of telepathy for now
learning a language the old-fashioned
way will still give you better results
than any currently available computer
program but this is no easy task and the
sheer number of languages in the world
as well as the increasing interaction
between the people who speak them will
only continue to spur greater advances
in automatic translation perhaps by the
time we encounter intergalactic
life-forms we'll be able to communicate
with them through a tiny gizmo or we
might have to start compiling that
dictionary after all
you